to some other news now a metro police  officer who lost his life to cobia 19  will be honored for all of his work  helping others in our community  lieutenant eric lloyd is one of nearly  300 police officers across our country  to die of covit since the pandemic  started he was the president of the  injured police officers fund  that's a nonprofit that raises money for  families of officers  injured or killed in the line of duty  the heroes  live forever 5k walk it is tomorrow from  8 to 11 o'clock  at police memorial park that's right  near cheyenne and hualapai  money raised will benefit the injured  police officers fund  you can participate or if you can't go  you can also donate at  brothersoftheshield.com it's a great  event